the Infinity stones create what you
experience is the flow of time remove
one of the stones and up those splits
once we're done with the stones we can
return each one to its own timeline at
the moment it was taken so
chronologically in that reality it never
left before creation itself there were
six singularity then the universe
exploded into existence and the remnants
of these systems were forged into
concentrated ingots infinity stone to
transform my universe back
[Music]
[Music]
we were unstoppable I was his weapon the
conquests that built Asgard's Empire one
by one of realms became ours but then
simply because my ambition outgrew his
he banished me their King fells
I'm with you to the end of the line I
just don't know when to give up do you
I feel
[Music]
[Music]
good luck on your mission captain good
luck on your project doctor
well I'm Howard Stark hi should that
don't pull it
yeah they didn't open it dizzy yeah they
did you better get down
[Music]
huge rumble throughout the cosmos ship
the moon and the Sun in the starry sky
so from all of us at Stark Industries I
would like to personally Tony what are
you doing back there what is that
put that back put it back where you got
it from
ah jellybeans daddy and I had a
last-minute business trip so Rose is
gonna stay with you for a few days no I
don't want you to go she didn't hesitate
[Music]
easy
whose likes you she doesn't typically
take to people early start to your
morning Oh
late night actually I can't sleep when
there's work to do sound familiar
flying your plane's never feels like
work my name is not Lawson
my real name is Marvel and I come from a
planet called hollow true you'll be a
great man someday I'll get the bags you
will return home at once or you will
face the council and inform them of your
crimes he drew on me
[Music]
I need some truth tell me about this
dream anything you know you have a rough
day agent fury it was cool you know had
a space invasion big car chase got to
watch an alien autopsy typical 9:00 to
5:00
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll be hearing from us from the
strategic homeland then just call us
shield for the hell are you Nick Fury
director of Shi
[Music]
if I tells you we were putting the team
together
who's we
[Music]
buddy we're adjourned we're darker today
you've been at the life
[Applause]
[Music]
major girl you CEO you're giving away
all your stuff
you let your friend fly away with your
soup now if I didn't know better you
don't know better I didn't give it to
him he took
[Music]
[Music]
what is power doctor we can figure out
how to tap it may be unlimited I don't
care what time it is
this one's waited lying off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to challenge them is to court death
[Music]
if it's all the same to you I'll have
that drink now
all right get him on his feet doot line
get your hands off and Disclosure to
pull my pin that is America's air
[Music]
strange is meant to be the best of us so
we must have done it for a reason
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I didn't do it for him
that's very wise a few jasm a kind you
knows it Haydn's they have from the
future I was raised by
[Music]
the only matter I do not take seriously
boy youth your politics for me demeanors
that have a powdered child and
apparently you alienated my favorite
daughter these couriers can use this
tone down the aisle civilizations like
wheat in a field
[Music]
[Music]
I know and you have the chance to prove
it
who are you consider me a guide to you
and to all who seek the soul stone oh
good you tell us where it is then we'll
be on our way
Liebchen
if only it were that easy
[Music]
you killed my mother I tried so hard to
find the form suited you capable of
displaying the guardians of the galaxy
you think I should call him
[Music]
ventures fine I'll do it myself
you can see
[Music]
[Music]
hypocrite
[Music]
[Music]
just burned me in the ocean but my
ancestors that jump from ships because
they knew death was better than bondage
let them drive
[Music]
real ones not bloggers when you're ready
let you try that on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kid that's the wizard get on it
[Music]
what is this what the hell is happening
[Music]
[Music]
you know your team's you know your
missions get the stones get them back
[Music]
I knew it
Avengers Assemble
[Music]
[Music]
well that's right
put the stools back I thought
maybe I'll try someone that live Tony
was telling me again
fire all the clues
[Music]
there you have it folks conclusive proof
that Spiderman was responsible for the
brutal murder of Mysterio spider-man's
name is Peter Parker
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching new rock stars
2019 update of the full MCU timeline
this year's made trickier with the time
meddling of Avengers endgame and the
multiple time periods of Captain Marvel
Black Widow
I can't wait for next year's to go all
the way back to the eternal no just
kidding that kind of can't wait for that
subscribe to new rock stories here on
youtube at follow me and he a boston
calling you rock stars at me rock stars
thanks for watching fight